hello readers
let's argue
in writing argument is a kind of fight
but i think it is unwise to think of it
as a one-way conversation the best
arguments do not plunge forward
heedlessly they do not steamroll
opposition rather they seek out opposing
arguments and incorporate them good
readers pay attention to how authors
acknowledge opposing viewpoints in an
argument doing this makes it easier to
decide how well thought out an argument
is and determine whether the author is
knowledgeable and thoughtful in their
position
now i do not practice the martial art of
wing chun but that style of self-defense
is famous for techniques that block and
strike at the same time your opponent's
fist comes in you redirect it away from
your body and in that same motion
continue your momentum into its own
immediate counter-strike
acknowledging the existence of opposing
viewpoints has two main applications
which are pretty different
first maybe you're not on any side of
the argument and you wish to
straightforwardly describe the conflict
like a journalist reporting on a lawsuit
it's a journalist's responsibility to
truthfully portray the full scope of
information on a topic bringing every
piece of relevant and plausible
information to bear
the author provides equal time to the
disputants and tries not to provide
their own opinion here
that could look like this miss adeyemi
contended that mr dupont stole the
cookies from her cookie jar and that
furthermore she had baked those cookies
in the first place thus strengthening
her claim to the said cookies of the 24
cookies baked by miss adiemi she alleges
that 10 of them were taken by mr dupont
mr dupont however contended that as he
was the person who made the cookie jar
for miz arayemi in the ceramics class he
took he is entitled to the occasional
cookie he does not dispute the ten
cookie figure adding only that they were
delicious judge wong upon reviewing
testimony from both parties sided with
ms arayemi saying that you are not
entitled to a cookie just for being a
good friend one time and that next time
mr dupont should ask for permission
now looking at that situation my
personal opinion is that it is
inappropriate to steal your friend's
cookies an opinion that any right
thinking person should share but
injecting opinion may not be appropriate
in all cases so okay that's the first
case reporting on multiple sides of a
dispute without getting involved
yourself
now the second reason the second
application for including opposing
viewpoints in an argumentative piece of
writing is that wing chun thing the
block as you strike technique it makes
your argument stronger if you anticipate
possible objections to it address them
and strike them down all the while still
making your argument in the first place
let's take this example from the website
this piece is about the lost colony at
roanoke a bunch of english settlers
disappeared under uncertain
circumstances for reasons still unknown
and the author's trying to make the case
that although theories for the
disappearance exist the truth is still
beyond our grasp
so in order to make that case they
address several different theories that
attempt to explain the disappearance
many people have tried to solve the
mystery of the lost colony historians
and archaeologists have searched for
answers for hundreds of years some
possible solutions are a native people
killed the colonists on roanoke island b
the colonists were all killed on roanoke
island by disease c their town was
washed away by a hurricane and the
people drowned or d they all left
roanoke island and went to live in some
other place
now watch what the author does as they
systematically go through each theory
and address it i've i've only excerpted
the first two so let's look at those
first two a when john white got back to
roanoke island in 1590 he did not find
any bones or bodies or any signs of
fighting
bones last a long time if native people
had killed the colonists there would
probably have been some remains or other
signs of violence we can guess that the
colonists were not killed on roanoke
island
b when the english first came to
virginia they're using a 16th century
spelling they brought diseases with them
such as flu and smallpox that were new
to the native communities they had no
immunity against them and many died very
quickly letters written by the colonists
tell us that the english remained
healthy and remember no bones or bodies
or graves were found we can guess that
the colonists did not all die of disease
so the authors saying that these events
are unlikely taking the theories
seriously and then thinking them through
to their conclusions but demonstrating
why they don't seem very likely
explanations
why do they think it's unlikely that
native people killed those colonists
there aren't any remains or signs of
combat
why does it seem unlikely that they died
of diseases there are no graves or
remains the thesis is nobody knows why
here are two counters to it basically
saying here's why and the author says
here's why these are unlikely to be true
which weakens those counter-arguments
and strengthens the original
block
strike my overall point is this
don't ignore the potential counters to
your argument incorporate them analyze
them and redirect their energy into your
own position
and when you read notice if the author
is acknowledging counters or ignoring
them
if they ignore them you should be
suspicious
why are they ignoring them
if you can answer that then you can
learn anything
david out